do you think your eyes are a little too
smoky for every day
I'm going through a phase is that okay
with you Ariana Grande shading her old
self it feels like the next version of
me feels like this a step forward yeah
Ari pokes fun and a tick tock clip for
her beauty line REM Beauty I've been
doing my homework and I want to talk to
you about something do you think your
eyes are a little too smoky for every
day
I'm going through a phase is that okay
with you sure okay in the video Ariana
speaks to her past self and appears
completely recognizable in the pop
star's previous signature beat I wanna
be myself but also like what comes with
that is crazy Ari captions the clip me
to the old me who wouldn't dare be seen
without a thick cat eye and an overdrawn
lip do whatever you want whatever you
want whatever feels natural be yourself
this comes nearly two months after she
addressed fans making online comments
about her body and a post on tick tock
in the rare video Ariana shared her
response to fans who were concerned
about her health and encouraged them to
be gentler and less comfortable
commenting on other people's bodies even
if you are coming from a loving place in
a Caring Place that person probably is
working on it or has a support system
that they are working on it with and
you never know so be gentle with each
other and with yourselves I'm happy life
is good she also shared a message of
true beauty coming from within I think
you're beautiful no matter what you're
going through no matter what weight no
matter what
how you like to do your makeup these
days no matter what
cosmetic procedures you've had or not or
anything
um yeah I just think
you're beautiful I really you know I
feel like my
fans are
a very very very important part of my
life like in a very real way
um
they're like friends to me they're like
family to me and I'm very sharing I'm
very open I think that me being open
with my fans and my supporters is like a
very important thing because like it's
like life you know what I mean so like
it's beautiful
foreign